we've come a long way from stealing DVD
players in Los Angeles Chase and Momoa
an extended family and a Sci-Fi
escalation here's what you missed in the
fast X trailer the new Fast X trailer
May clock in at just under four minutes
long but that's still more than enough
time for Vin Diesel's Dom and the rest
of the crew to wax poetic about family
for a while all told the word family is
spoken on five occasions throughout the
trailer
family family family
that's a rate of more than one family
per minute for those keeping track all
this talk of family especially tracks
with the plot of fast X the trailer
suggests that the 10th Mainline film in
the franchise is going to be more about
family than ever Dante clearly has it
out for Dom on a personal level
believing the racer to be responsible
for the loss of his family as such it
looks like Dom's own family will be the
prime targets of the villains Revenge
plot one particularly alarming shot of
the trailer sees Dom's son and Brian
once again getting kidnapped
that's the problem with having such a
big family how do you choose the ones
you save
and speaking of Dante he tends to steal
the show with his outrageous and
vindictive behavior from the very first
moments of his appearance and voice over
one can tell that this new antagonist
means business but it might not be just
business that brings this new character
into Dom's life it seems as if this
Dante character is actually connected to
events from Fast Five and may actually
be related to the villain of that movie
the politician and drug lord Hernan
Reyes in some form based on some
interview comments it seems like he
might be the son of that past antagonist
speaking with variety Mamoa explained
how much he enjoyed working on fastx and
his time as a villain by saying time of
my life I get to be the bad guy finally
I've been the good guy for a while
Dante's very sadistic and androgynous
and he's a bit of a peacock he's got a
lot of issues this guy he's definitely
got some daddy issues in a Twist that
surprises no one fastx adds yet another
villain turned Ally to the fast Saga
with John Cena's Jacob Toretto
officially joining the family while we
only get a brief look at Dom and Jacob's
new relationship it's worth noting that
Jacob's tone indicates the brothers are
on good terms after making amends at the
end of F9 fans also get a look at Jacob
taking on a group of tactical soldiers
after combing through the shots of the
trailer it seems that someone presumably
Dante sent the soldiers after Mia and
Brian Dom's son but Jacob comes to the
rescue
with Brie Larson and Jason Momoa joining
The Fast and Furious franchise it's easy
to overlook the first appearance of Alan
richson as agent Grimes the trailer
shows him getting ready to perform some
tactical shooting but it's unclear who
his targets are Mamoa is obviously the
big bad but the film's heroes have been
known to rub law enforcement the wrong
way in the past will they get into it
with Rhymes or will he help them stop
the bad guys if the history of this
franchise tells us anything it's likely
that both scenarios will happen based on
the little Glimpse we've seen of Rhymes
so far it seems that the character will
fill a Hobbes type role the absence of
Dwayne Johnson's no-nonsense agent has
left a void in the franchise that still
hasn't been filled yet but richson is a
solid choice to lead the next wave of
highly trained cops into action
furthermore the Jack Reacher star is
more than capable of playing a
convincing Action Hero so he should feel
right at home in this franchise already
if there's one thing that's become as
consistent with the Fast and Furious
franchise as cars and Coronas its old
enemies patching things up and clinking
bottles by the end of a heavily fueled
installment somehow we managed to move
on from the Shaw Brothers Owen and
Deckard battling against Dom and his
family when they saved his son in the
fate of the furious with that said the
air is still in need of clearing between
two of the franchise's most iconic
characters besides playing it safe with
plenty of nods back to previous films
one of the biggest takeaways to seeing
Deckard and Han sharing the screen they
may look to be on speaking terms here
but the chances of them getting in a
scrap to let off some long overdue steam
beforehand has to happen right the
people have waited too long for justice
for Han and now we might be getting it
for a saga that has never once attempted
to hide its most Bonker story choices
the tale of Toretto has done the
unthinkable in the final moments of this
new trailer it actually has stumped us
over what's going on between Letty and
Cipher if Dom playing tug of war with
some helicopters had our Jaws dropping
seeing the longtime villain wake up with
Dominic's sweetheart has to scratching
our chins and reaching a shocking Theory
are are they about to do a body swap
it's become an Unwritten rule after Fast
Five that anything could happen in this
science-defying series we thought it
reached a limit for a franchise that has
sent two of its characters to space in a
clapped out Pontiac Fiero as well as
revealing our leading man had a brother
he didn't mention four nine films and
yet something about those final few
seconds screams face off with both
characters appearing like they're
looking in a mirror only not is this
really what's happening or is this
Theory simply ludicrous
or maybe
you're just a dumb
we can only wait and see
[Music]